Russia's conducting airstrikes on the
last major rebel-held area in Syria
after a pause of more than three weeks
the strikes are hitting such sections
rather in the province in northwestern
Syria they come after warning from
President Trump that attacks would be a
grave humanitarian mistake Debora patta
is monitoring the fighting from Istanbul
Deborah good morning good morning whilst
there is no direct correlation between
the two the Russian airstrikes come just
hours after President Trump tweeted his
warning Russia says they are in
retaliation for weaponized drone attacks
yesterday there come as Syria is bracing
itself for a final showdown in Italy
which is the last remaining rebel
stronghold but there are also nearly 3
million civilians in the area and the
anisha Nations has warned of a
humanitarian catastrophe if a massive
assault goes ahead President Trump has
urged Russia and Iran not to allow a
reckless attack to occur Russia Iran and
Turkey will meet on Friday to discuss it
live which Russia says is a nest of
terrorists backed by Russian military
muscle Syria has been amassing forces in
a blip in preparation for a massive
final assault and here in Turkey which
borders in Lib Turkish military
reinforcements have been sent in the
hundreds to the area Nora
all right Debora patta in Istanbul thank
you